what really happened behind the scenes
during the making of this gonzo action
spectacle
it's time to start your engines because
we're taking a look at what you don't
know about 1979's mad max
george miller was the man in the
director's chair on the original mad max
movie but any and all success that the
mad max series has enjoyed over the
years must be shared by his co-producer
byron kennedy
the late great producer of both mad max
and mad max 2 kennedy served as the
second set of brains behind this series
of action-packed masterpieces
after meeting at a film workshop at
melbourne university miller and kennedy
first collaborated on a short called
violence in the camera part 1
which was both the parody and dissection
of the world of movie violence
the short garnered acclaim across the
country and gave kennedy and miller the
confidence they needed to start their
own production company which they aptly
named kennedy miller
although kennedy tragically passed away
in a helicopter crash in 1983
george miller has kept on producing
movies under the kennedy miller
production banner keeping the spirit of
his collaborator alive
kennedy's legacy also lives on in the
form of an award for excellence in
movies and television and australia
aptly called the byron kennedy award
while the latter mad max films would
delve into the fantasies of a
post-apocalyptic society run amok this
wasn't exactly where the ideas started
out for this unique end of the world
story
when george miller and former journalist
james mccosland set out to create the
world of roving bikers and cops out for
revenge there was actually some helpful
real world inspiration to get their
wheels turning
arguably the greatest influence for
miller and mccosland was ripped straight
from the headlines that being the real
world global oil crisis of the 1970s
when shutoffs to international oil
exports led to vast oil shortages miller
and mccoslan noted long lines of
motorists lining up for gas
and started to extrapolate what might
happen if this desire for fossil
fuel was taken to a disturbingly
dangerous degree
governor he's going to police this
gasolin situation i will not take the
blame for this thing i will not take the
crap and the harassment from these
customers he would go on to become one
of the most famous
and then infamous film stars in the
world but before all the blockbusters
and controversial headlines that made
him instantly recognizable to moviegoers
around the globe
mel gibson earned his action hero
stripes in mad max
after starring in the initial mad max
film gibson would cement his glory in
the next two mad max features while also
landing starring roles in a wide variety
of films that included action hits like
the lethal weapon franchise
as well as comedies like what women want
but it almost never happened
when looking for actors for mad max
miller and his team called in a group of
recent graduates from the national
institute of dramatic art to try out for
the menacing young men who populate the
film
the first time gibson went in to
audition however he'd recently been in a
fight and was almost unrecognizable due
to all the bruises on his face i sort of
took on
half a rugby team and it was just it
didn't work out too well on my end
so i was looking pretty bad luckily
gibson returned for a second audition
after his face heal
and he was looking a little more movie
star charismatic as he tells it george
miller offered him the part on the spot
with mel gibson set to stars max it
wasn't long before the rest of the
movie's stellar cast was thrown together
the ensemble miller assembled around his
star consisted of a heap of australian
and new zealand native performers
including hugh keysburn as the
villainous tow cutter steve bisley is
max's partner goose and initially rosie
bailey as max's wife
jesse rockatansky four days into
shooting however bayley was involved in
a motorcycle accident that left her
unable to complete the film
setting production back multiple weeks
bayley's role was eventually recast with
joanne samuel bringing a courageous edge
to what could have been a throwaway role
it just goes to show that not even a
replacement casting could put a stop to
miller and his team and their mission to
bring the story to the screen
would you be surprised to hear that the
filming of mad max was just as chaotic
and dangerous as the action of the film
itself
being a low budget below the radar ultra
violent mess of a production much of the
filmmaking reflected that ragtag style
of putting things together
all of it unfolding over the span of a
crammed together six-week shoot
from closing roads without proper
permits not being able to use proper
walkie-talkies as to not get tangled
with police radio interference to the
general chaos that comes from having to
film a series of real-life car crashes
and having to wreck piles upon piles of
cars
the filming of mad max would likely make
a worthy entry into the mad max saga all
on its own
even after filming rap the production
was no walk in the park
for much of their editing process miller
and his crew had to work out of a
friend's apartment on a homemade editing
rig
miller would edit the film itself in the
living room while the sound editing crew
cut the sound in the kitchen
most of the chaos of mad max comes
courtesy of tow cutter and his rampaging
biker gang that spread fear and violence
wherever they go
they're an integral part of building
miller's world of futurist australia
where the rules of society are beginning
to crumble
and characters like the knight rider and
johnny the boy are able to go as wild as
they do
there's a good reason these men are as
menacing as they appear in mad max
they were members of an actual biker
gang the majority of extras used in the
film were members of outlaw motorcycle
clubs in australia providing an even
greater sense of authenticity to the
chute
miller even asked them to use their own
bikes and ride them all the way from
sydney to melbourne as their budget
couldn't allow for aerial transport
not a very glamorous beginning but the
trip was worth it to bring that extra
bit of grit and reality to the film
world
even as it became a huge box office
success in its own home country of
australia
not everyone was thrilled to welcome the
ultra-violent antics of mad max into
their cinemas
in one of australia's closest
neighboring nations new zealand the film
was initially banned upon its release
due to overwhelming similarities between
events depicted in the movie and a
real-life incident in which someone was
burned alive in their car
the film would eventually be released
there in 1983 after the success of mad
max 2.
its reputation at sweden however lasted
for quite a while longer
there was no specific scene that caused
the ban there rather just an all-around
distaste for the excessive violence of
the film that kept swedish audiences
from enjoying the future for decades
it wasn't until 2005 that the nation
decided to finally lift the ban and let
max roam free in sweden along with the
rest of the world
even with its bold vision brilliant
stunts and heart-stopping action the
general response to mad max upon release
on australia was anything but rapturous
for the bulletin australian commentator
philip adams described the film as
having quote all the emotional uplift of
mein kampf
hardly the kind of reviews you'd like to
get for your debut feature but surely
the american critics wouldn't be as
harsh as their australian counterparts
actually they were even harsher upon its
american release tom buckley of the new
york times deemed the film
ugly and incoherent while stephen king
outright called the film a turkey
they say all press is good press but
it's hard to imagine george miller being
happy with the initial critical reaction
to matt max
many films add an english language dub
for us screenings if they're made in a
foreign language but mad max might be
one of the only films that was made in
english and still ended up getting
re-dubbed for its american release
upon its initial us release in 1980 the
entire film's dialogue
track was redubbed to give the film's
characters so-called american accents
this included instances of removing
australian slang and general attempts to
make the film sound more comprehensible
to american audiences
even if the voices sounded downright
silly out of these actors mouths
when do we go for a ride after the film
caught on and spawned the blockbuster
franchise we know and loved today
the original dub was eventually brought
to the u.s providing audiences with a
proper glimpse as to how the film was
supposed to sound
while fury road was the first entry in
the mad max saga to achieve any sort of
academy award recognition
the original mad max still had its fair
share of awards recognition at
australia's very own film awards
ceremony
then known as the afi but today known as
the australian academy of cinema and
television arts awards
for the 1979 awards ceremony the movie
received seven nominations
including for best film and best
direction and racked up three wins for
editing
original music score and sound that same
year leading man mel gibson did indeed
win a best actor award at the ceremony
for an entirely different film
gibson wasn't even nominated for his
turn in mad max instead being recognized
and rewarded for his other lead film
role that year
in the romantic drama tim in which he
played the dramatic role of a
developmentally challenged builders
worker
though global fame eluded him for this
particular role there's no question
which of gibson's roles in 1979 would
forever live in the worldwide audience's
imagination
with the release of mad max and its
lively reception offers from hollywood
started to roll in for george miller
fairly quickly
according to unconfirmed legend one of
the potential projects that might have
been most intriguing to miller was he
offered to direct the next big sylvester
stallone movie first blood
another film that although few could
have suspected it at the time would also
go on to jump start a highly successful
and long-running action franchise
whether or not that story is actually
true we do know that after mad max was
released miller spent quite a bit of
time trying to write and develop another
project before he finally gave up on
getting it made
after much deliberation miller realized
that with his first flush of success he
could return to the world of mad max
with a bigger budget a bigger vision and
a bigger sense of destruction to bring
to the silver screen
thus he threw himself back into the
dystopia of his own making and brought
mad max 2 the road warrior out into the
world
and the rest his futuristic hard-hitting
cinema history
more than three decades after his
directing debut george miller returned
to the world of mad max with a film that
is widely recognized as one of the best
action movies of all time
mad max fury road took miller's
wide-eyed aspirations as a young
filmmaker and transform them into an
apocalyptic descent into action valhalla
while there's a huge difference between
fury road and the original mad max in
terms of production value
one element they do share is a key actor
in both films
hugh keys burn perhaps better known
today for his performance as the
devilishly disgusting and mordant joe
and fury road
his delightfully villainous performance
there had its origins back in the
original mad max in which he starred as
the lead villain toe cutter while
certainly quite a bit older and with a
starkly different look
keysburn's commitment to embodying the
villainy and chaos in the mad max
universe was a huge part of bringing
miller's vision to life
but it's not for him it's for me
[Music]
papa
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you